[Music]
such an amazing man and it really is
love my life and actually hope one day
that we can work it out and get back
together I saw some of the comments that
she made and I think that's like I said
she's she's searching for something
so I know I can't force her to find it
but I don't want I don't want this to
fall apart because of speculation up I
think he's doing this yeah or I think he
feels this way yeah John Cena responding
to et's interview with Nikki Bella
during Tuesday's Today Show he was guest
co-hosting with Kathie Lee and Hoda he
was with Nikki and sister brie on Monday
my biggest thing is I just want to live
the rest of our lives happy and
hopefully that's together also Monday
John told today he was hoping for a
reconciliation with his s I don't have
any other hopes other than maybe one day
that we can work it out
fans will see the relationship drama
play out on the new season of total
Bella's to be honest since we've gotten
engaged John and I have probably shared
our bed together maybe 30 days total out
of like six months or 40 days
see where it can take you and what
you'll get faced with with certain size
shoes you know like they do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]